points the door she got on the air
breathe is sex in the passing lane
two-on-one George
[Applause]
Oh George doing everything in the third
quarter he's got 14 points it's all
Thunder tonight for position Michael is
expected to be a contribute there's a
steal by Paul George took it right away
from Jackson throw it down amid lights
to see little pep in his death Paul
George's took the router on oh [ __ ]
beaches are except
you know it's kind of like you when you
hold that piece of cake and I want it
I'm just gonna ration toward to the
corner
the customer at the end there hit just
look well there's a hack on the left arm
yeah I feel you Stephen Adam because
you're thinking that's not a foul
I just bodied up to the bucket and Paul
George with the two-handed flush
Paul George man he just makes a quick
committed step to the baseline both
right by Wesley Matthews and when he's
going at that fast there's just no way
that weak side help there
[Applause]
eight Oklahoma City Sprague Steven Adams
started it with the turnovers Eddie I
got the least blood that is the way by
Ferguson they hit a head the Patterson
the lock
[Applause]
Nelson the feed was impeccable the
Thunder livin large and Durant goes
great annamund loses the ball George to
the rim and the stop Durant
what Diallo swaps Durant tried to go
behind the back it ends up in the hands
of George reverse stuff and you take it
you run their meal and there's a
turnover
good pressure off the ball ball George
Thwaites hesitates to the dogs up above
the rim that's not what you call like
that the defense either Hoffman what
Paul George he clearly two guys he had
to play Mickelson Nicholas the tool on
the perimeter
hitting the three Stoffel Oh Nuggets
player the inbounds play George that
step the jumper and took it to the rim
that one he found a great sweet spot
look at this dude settle for the outside
shot put the ball on the floor go
straight to the basket while he's not in
the ballgame the shot blocking that this
Cleveland team does not like to take a
lot of threes
like what has turned into the NBA
Revolution is called charge when the
first of acceleration got to the rim
that throws it down underneath the
free-throw line just continuing to
attack glass that frontcourt of Atlanta
man with that that's what you want to
see you don't get here you high tunnel
valve front
Josh the stop was just great
anticipation man this is why he's
needing a mph Steelers you know if I'm
playing against Paul George I'm afraid
to pass the ball that has to thunder it
just dried up things on the inside shots
aren't falling on the outside now George
goes to the rim and a two-handed stop it
is that first of acceleration and the
elevation time to put pressure
on the nets
thunderous dog off the fee from West
brought her in this fourth quarter
dependences hung off their hat elevation
hey time George
takes it strong soars to the rim for the
slab Paul George's start you feel
comfortable right here this is gonna be
a very good game Ferguson and his
couples are back in Thunder states down
defensively George gets behind the pack
and soars with a flush it's had the
energy here tonight as Westbrook got it
ahead to Paul George you can't stop down
I like that the activity on defense and
once again the Thunder just giving it
that painted area just like a wrecking
ball with Jackson
George for the two-handed slam
Paul George we saw the threes Michael
and write to the Wright from Donovan
Mitchell George right down the lane and
Paul George now has 30 on the night
he's so fluent with the basketball as he
splits the double-team sorry
floats it up off the back of the rim
inching closer up ahead by pg-13 nobody
could stop that the shake Paul George
and Paul's
taken away by shrewder and he gives
George a little Christmas gift after the
D on the other end lack any type of
elevation test shot folks at the fast
break opportunity 17 nothing now
Westbrook greats another one this time
it's George on the other end and the
windmill boom you just let the seal look
what's happening it's creating a lot of
heart out there a lot of flow to the
game kind of set Luca doctor up and
watch out here we go Joe
[Applause]
and getting good looks old bad pass
stolen by Westbrook Westbrook measures
throws it up for Paul George dude on
selfish play Oh George fall for the
technical
for hanging on the rim looks in himself
up yep yep
here in this quarter Paul George - Mike
beautiful pass and George with the slam
Duchenne OnPoint delivery little
backdoor play and Russell Westbrook
delivers the pass
Paul George continuing his advantage
I tried to get too good to the pass a
little in service for Paul George and
Showtime the three-ball another
possession out the ball this far out
front
you literally create your own defense
she slammed the Bible Authority
that was loud
there's George puts it on the floor he
spins to
[Applause]
[Music]
that's why he was open for that riemann
george weaving through traffic for the
two-handed slam upon a strong strong
event sparring houston here at the
Toyota Center nineteen and eight is
Martin fumbles it lost in grip defense
from Steven Adams George drives and
finishes this is what the Thunder do
better than anybody in the league they
forced turnovers and tournament two
points
Gordon sits down Austin razuna as his
iman shumpert chopper dueling his first
game with the Rockets after being
acquired from Sacramento and yet off
another turnover OKC scores again
Westbrook comes in and takes it right
out of his hands throws it ahead to
George George lands at home none Aires
again OKC been their best defensively
will they forced the turnovers for best
when they're forcing turnovers good
collapse on the ball by Westbrook and
then George running for layups and it's
snapped what was thirty three
consecutive amends for the Blazers was
beating going into fourth quarter
Paul George I mean this is this
beautiful this beautiful basketball pick
and roll Camino situation pump get
downhill run and there's nobody back
there
[Music]
New Orleans had an eight-point lead in
that first quarter and a save by Adams
Georgia back throws it down Moses get
one foot dirt to dirt there by harden
Georgia here's the reverse 360 the road
s was shot and ends up being comfortable
anyway in a breakaway for George
[Applause]
how about that overtime game three
minutes left down to when you go with a
windmill and here is Paul George
fresh off that game-winning shot high
arctor by Steven Adams as we open up
this game talk about Paul George I mean
loses the basketball Adams right there
sharp to pick up that loose chicken bird
can't get that one to fall I'm
interested to see this matchup because
personal
with that one for MVPs 9o run here in
the first water for the Thunder will be
back
[Applause]
he really build Russell Westbrook out on
that play trouble in Georgia where
Monday night before the Thunder returned
home nice clock beautiful pass Steven
Adams finding Paul George who was
slicing his way to the rim in the post
and on the shot block insist there by
Nerlens Noel it's just some swipe it at
the ball for suppose the misstep hey
George rising up for the Thunder is slam
that's how you shoot it when you take a
shot that's how you do it but you don't
do it like this that's this ball Jules
and me looking him get up in the air on
this play I have offensive rebounds I
mean this guy he's averaging nearly 15
and 10 but just like that that play
right there is what he's capable on
good story touches George mugs it down
and leave Steven Adams for the LOB what
do I take a heart charging or halftime
benefit but there it is right there
Steven alice is even an active tree sent
it up with a nice basket charity crushes
at home rightful pace sure hunter with
the little skip over to Paul George
little punctuation here to end half
number one the Thunder had to come back
on Friday night down by 10 left to come
back again here at halftime what a great
story about him miss MacDermott takes it
in knock knock
George on the break and torch
finishes with the slam you wonder how
much energy Denver is going to have
[Applause]
the rim as the Thunder losing the game
here in this third quarter
led by pg-13 set the tone in the pace of
the game and he does just about as good
a job as anyone starting the game off
with his intensity as John gets the gun
6-3 okay see but Lakers with a handle on
the basketball and it's thrown away they
lead in steals
[Applause]
in steals
Paul George if you're asking for trouble
as he's got his second field already and
his second flush off of that the glass
must be whenever you look at Steven
Adams numbers over the last three games
20 and 10 being more aggressive than
this this TV get steel
defensive the office really
[Music]
to me it's the rebounding that's
astounding you know of course someone of
his talents gonna has George takes it
dumps it he's gonna get double figures
points thunders defense has really
gotten good this quarter my speed inside
of George finally sees one go through
the roof with this 13 of the last 14
they finally get one the high percentage
two-handed slam what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content